I think you're really gonna like this one.
Uh, Leora Trump Lira. Trump is of daughter-in-law
of Donald Trump.
I guess she must be married to Eric Trump
because Don junior is divorced and dating
one of the former Fox news ladies, I believe.
In any case, Lera Trump goes on Fox news.
She goes on Fox news to be interviewed about
the Trump Syria Kurds fiasco.
Now, before we even look at what she said,
why would you interview not even the son of
Trump or the daughter of Trump, but Trump's
kids wife about Syria when her background
has nothing to do with anything that would
make her have an informed position on Syria.
Her background is a story producer on television.
I don't know why you interview Larry Trump
about Syria to begin with, but let's not focus
on that right now because that'll get us off
track.
Okay.
Fox news says we've, we've just have to, we
have to have Leora Trump on and talk to her
about Syria and the Kurds.
Okay.
Lera Trump defends Donald Trump's harebrained
and completely disastrous actions in Syria
by saying, effectively the average American
is ignorant.
So there she explains that, listen, most Americans
don't even know who the Kurds are.
Trump was right, which if you understand,
not even formal logic, but just in a colloquial
sense, how you put an argument together doesn't
really compute as an argument.
Check out the video and imagine the dystopia
we're living in where number one, the president's
daughter in law is making a political political
analysis of what's going on in the middle
East despite it having nothing to do whatsoever
with her background or area of expertise.
And imagine that it counts as political analysis
to defend a policy by saying there are lots
of ignorant Americans
and give it an unanticipated victory to four
American adversaries, Russia, Iran, the Syrian
government, and the Islamic state.
Your response tonight, well, Shannon, I think
we should start with the fact that if you
asked the average American out there, I think
they would have to Google who are the Kurds
and why is America even over there fighting
this war?
We were supposed to be there for 30 days.
We've been there for 10 years and when the
president campaign in 2016 he was very clear
that he wanted to stop all of these endless
Wars that he wanted to bring our troops back
home.
That's
right.
Shannon, what do I think about a thoughtful
piece in the New York times?
Seriously assessing the grave nature of what's
been done here, the history, the geopolitics
and other considerations.
What I think is that the average American
has no idea who the Kurds are.
Oh, and so then what she also tells lies,
we were supposed to be there 30 days.
She says, that's not true.
There was no such deadline established at
the time.
Now that might've been a mistake.
You can say there should have been a deadline
established at the beginning, but there was
no such deadline established at the beginning.
She says, we've been there 10 years.
It's 2019 that would mean 2009 Obama first
committed troops in 2015 you can disagree
with the decision, but you don't get to measure
time in some different way.
That's four to five years ago.
You could be overly charitable and say, well,
the Obama decision really was linked to the
coalition that first went in in 2014 like,
okay, maybe you stretch it to 2014 but these
are just lies.
It's lie after lie after lie.
And it's an example of the self reinforcing
feedback loop of ignorance that we have in
this country.
Understand how it works.
You have rampant ignorance and a total lack
of critical thinking skills in some States
like Texas, it's by design because they, they've
decided we are not going to teach critical
thinking, uh, in schools.
We're not going to teach philosophy in schools.
We're not going to build the base of the knowledge
pyramid as I described it, that prepares people
to really critically think about the messages
that they're getting in media.
So you get that.
Then you get those clueless people that lack
those skills brought on to do political analysis
and using the fact that there are ignorant
Americans to justify the terrible policies
of an administration.
So what is implied by Leora Trump's comment
is that since many Americans don't know who
the Kurds are, what concern about them as
disingenuous concern trolling because nobody
even knows who they are.
Does she mean that since lots of Americans
don't know who the Kurds are, you can't possibly
care about people you don't personally know.
I mean, sadly that is an unfortunate reality
and the American right wing, uh, is more than
we'd like to admit.
We have so many of these stories of virulently
anti-gay Republicans who once they know someone
who's LGBT, a kid, a neighbor, whatever, all
of a sudden they develop an empathy and an
understanding for what's going on.
She may actually be right as a right winger,
which I guess she is.
I don't know.
A, she might be saying, I don't understand
how anyone could even feign support for Kurds
when they don't even know who they are because
I don't know.
I never cared about anybody.
I didn't meet personally.
Maybe that's what she means, but the message
is sickening, which is if Americans don't
know who the Kurds are, we can ignore that
they are and have been our allies.
They've helped us in the past.
They've helped us fight ISIS and Donald Trump
said that was one of his top priorities to
fight and defeat ISIS.
We can ignore all of that if Americans are
simply ignorant to who the Kurds are really
disturbing stuff on so many levels.
Again, that this even counts as a political
analysis is extraordinarily disturbing that
Leora Trump would be asked to comment about
middle East policy is laughable and maybe
more of a reflection of Fox news than of anything
else, and then of course in the end, the fact
that it's a ridiculous argument.
What does it matter if Americans do or don't
know who the Kurds are?
I pointed out on Twitter that there are hangers
on who without knowing any of the history
are taking hyper-partisan positions on this
one way or the other and that's not particularly
productive, but you don't need to personally
know the Kurds in order to care about the
policy.
That is going extremely astray, uh, uh, by
Donald Trump and coming from the white house.
And again, who suggested this policy because
it wasn't Trump's generals.
It wasn't the Pentagon, it wasn't the military.
We don't know exactly where or why Donald
Trump came up with this idea.
Let's take a quick break.
We have a tremendous program for you today.
Make sure that you're following me on Twitter
at [inaudible] Pacman.
Follow the show on Twitter at David Pakman
show.
And importantly,
we are back on Twitch after our 24 hour ban
at twitch.tv/david Pak, t